hey what's up guys I'm Brent rose tech
writer and Marine Mammal today I'm
feeling super super lazy and luckily
there's a new service for lazy asses
just like myself it's called magic you
just send off a text message and a real
human will field your request and have
it delivered to you this service is only
a few days old but it's already gone
viral and has a waiting list of 20,000
people but lucky me I got an invite so I
contacted my friends at Wired I asked if
we could have some petty cash to blow
and stress testing magic
they've given me 500 bucks so let's see
what we can do I want a meatball
sandwich do you want me to baal sandwich
oh yeah definitely
I'd love to meatball sandwiches meet all
sandwiches I screwed that up
no problem bread give us a couple
minutes to work our magic the orders on
the way should be there in 45 minutes
$25 you use this link to complete the
order see what happens pay with card or
Bitcoin booth so payment went through
and they said they received it want some
beer a couple bottles of Ninkasi tricera
hops yeah of course let me look into
that right now it's like just obscure
enough that it should be a challenge for
these guys we can get the brew to you in
about 45 minutes total should be 17
dollars what do you think I think yes so
we've got a bunch of requests is it
easier to do them one at a time tell us
what you want we'll let you know how we
can make it happen oh he left I need an
authentic Mexican wrestling mask and a
ukulele chord book oh snap hang tight we
can get this and the doorbell just rang
this is a wonderful moment in my life
hey has gone alright thank you much oh
yeah look better knowing that I'll deal
with sin effects yeah the laziness
behind the sandwich just makes the
sandwich all that much better is it the
kids or adult masks adult obviously
Mexican wrestling is not kids stuff
you can get this to you for $70 in about
an hour right keep a running total much
beer and ask we're not spending nearly
enough money right now doorbell the
string oh it's the beer ice cold beer do
I take the bucket too sweet
Thank You Man appreciate it in ice
that's a beautiful thing
Cheers let's get some more they've
done a really good job so far with goods
let's see how they do with services I
kind of like this hoodie can you have
someone go to the beta Brand store in
the mission and try on the Glen plaid
executive hoodie in a size medium take a
selfie of himself and send it to me so I
can see if it looks good
sure no problem let me get you an ETA
for that selfie also where's my
Mexican wrestling mask just kidding it's
been like almost 20 minutes they do not
currently carry that jacket but they do
carry it non plaid here's the selfie
would you like us to buy that one 45 and
you'd be all aware today 145 for the
most expensive hoodie sorry say that
again
oh okay I haven't seen the text yet oh
um I think we're okay ukulele chord buck
if you're happy yeah thank you very much
all I wanted was the dictionary they got
me a whole songbook we're just gonna
throw another scenario at them I'm
unexpectedly spending the night at a
friend's place
I need toothbrush toothpaste condolences
greeting card condoms and a houseplant
that's over three feet tall they say
Christmas only comes once a year
Oh check $45 I feel like this is going
pretty well I've got some beer and me
I've got a lot of meatball sandwich and
me really overpriced hoodie and a very
warm Mexican wrestling mask which is
apparently not authentic they just wrote
back okay about the stuff for your
sleepover we can get you everything for
$100 all right
I would really like
joint made of high CBD medicinal
cannabis and yes I have my medical
marijuana prescription with me okey
dokey we'll check on the cannabis - it's
so cheerful
obviously we're probably getting some
preferential treatment because they they
want to look good for this video they
can scale up and do this for for all of
their users then it'll be a pretty
impressive service yep that'll work it
is rode back the first step will be for
you to send us pictures of your driver's
license and prescription for medical
cannabis legally you will have to pay on
delivery to the dispensary we cannot pay
for your cannabis but we will help you
with this process it will be a 15 dollar
service fee and there's the doorbell the
celebration of life lived forever in the
memories of our loved ones with deepest
sympathy she's going to love that so I
kind of admire what they're doing with
the medicinal marijuana situation here
it certainly would be easier to just
find a dispensary on my own that
delivers but they're doing a really
admirable job what does knotek say I'm
sorry I didn't notice this there's a $50
minimum for this dispensary we can do 3
pre-rolls for $40 and add $15 Kiva
chocolate bytes if you'd like but let's
just do four joints thanks so much
order is confirmed enjoy your cannabis
final task for the day could you have
someone buy 10 sandwiches and distribute
them to the homeless around the mission
great
that will be $90 for the 10 sandwiches
plus delivery
sandwiches have been ordered from El
Jefe Tazo and mission this the text
received from our runner and adult 10
they were all really grateful it's
awesome hey how's gone right
yes oh yeah how are you nice to meet you
you have a driver's license I do well we
just think would be here that yep there
you go sweet all right Thank You Man
have a good one yet thank you you too oh
they give us five instead of four quite
the deal for 50 bucks so what do you
guys think is this the epitome of
American laziness and greed and
teittleman or is this kind of a cool
service or is it both let us know what
you think in the comments don't forget
to subscribe to Wired here and with that
we've spent all of the petty cash we
were allotted so there's only one thing
left to do
this is a scam is a ploy is this the
epitome of laziness or the essence of
joy is this magic Oh disgusting magic my
mask on fire feel like my mask might be
on fire